but if i don't become a true hero i'll
never be able to rejoin my father zeus
hold it zeus is your father right
zeus the big guy is your daddy
mr lightning bolts read me a book would
you dada
once upon a time
it's the truth police for a true hero
isn't measured by the size of his
strength
but by the strength
of his heart
[Music]
today we are learning english with
disney's classic animation hercules
if you're interested in greek mythology
as well as in inspiring adventures let's
embark on this epic journey together
in case you're new here the scenes we've
chosen have no spoilers you'll watch two
scenes from the movie learn the
vocabulary and then have the chance to
watch it again without subtitles
and if you want to keep learning with
the best disney movies and tv series so
you can finally watch them without
getting lost without missing the jokes
and without subtitles just click on the
subscribe button and bell down below
that's what diana did and she has seen a
massive improvement not only in her
pronunciation but also her vocabulary
[Music]
how sentimental
you know i haven't been this
choked up since i got a hunk of musa
caught in my throat huh
so this is an audience or a mosaic
hey how you doing looking good nice
dress so hades you finally mean it our
things in the underworld well they're
just fine you know a little dark a
little gloomy and there's always hay
full of dead people what are you gonna
do oh there's the little sunspot little
shnoochie and here is a sucker for the
little sucker ah here you go you
babe but unlike you gods lounging about
up here i regrettably have a full-time
gig that you by the way so charitably
bestowed on me
zeus so
can't love to but can't
you slow down you work yourself to death
work yourself to death
kill myself
if only
[Music]
in ancient greece the god zeus and hera
have a son named hercules while the
other gods are happy zeus's brother
hades is grumpy and jealous
hades has an evil plan to defeat zeus
and raw mount olympus however hercules
may get in his way and prevent him from
succeeding so before proceeding with his
plans hades has to come up with
something to get hercules out of his way
before we learn from the scene here are
a few fun facts
in ancient greek mythology zeus is the
sky and thunder god who rules as king of
the gods of mount olympus
hera is the goddess of women and family
and the sister and wife of zeus
mount olympus is the highest mountain in
greece and famous for being the home of
the greek gods
how sentimental
someone or something that is sentimental
is strongly influenced by emotional
feelings if you don't connect to your
feelings very often you may be a
rational person
take a look at how sentimental and
rational are used in these examples
here we are wow
now i've already had too much to drink
and i'm feeling sentimental but i'm
going to say something anyway which
nobody wants to admit but i think it's
probably true
what if
theoretically yeah they were little ogre
feet
oh
honey
let's try and be rational about this
have you seen a baby lately
you know i haven't been this
choked up since i got a hunkamusaka
caught in my throat huh
when you choke you stop breathing
because something is blocking your
throat the verb choke is commonly
followed by the preposition on
example hey don't eat too fast you can
choke on this piece of bread
when you are choked up you are unable to
speak or almost begin to cry because of
sadness or strong emotion
they're trapped kids
trapped
phil
this is great you're really choked up
about this aren't you come on
no i you know i have this terrible fear
a hunk means a large thick piece
especially of food we can say a hunk of
bread cheese or meat
mossaka is a greek dish consisting of
layers of potato aubergine mincemeat and
a bechamel sauce on top as you may have
noticed by the tone of his voice hades
is super sarcastic so here in this clip
he plays around with the meaning of the
word choke he is also not being
sentimental at
you all mean it to make it means to
complete something successfully
you made it somehow a little guy
you didn't give up did you
[Applause]
speaking of success if you want to
become a successful english learner i
highly recommend our fluent with friends
course you'll have fun learning lots of
native vocabulary expressions and
pronunciation with the first two seasons
of friends
you'll receive pdf power lessons every
week and gain access to our fluency
circle global community so that you're
never alone on your journey
the best part is you can try it for free
with our three-part masterclass
just click up here or the link down in
the description box below and we'll send
it straight to your email
are things in the underworld well
they're just fine you know a little dark
a little gloomy and as always a full of
dead people what are you gonna do the
underworld in greek mythology refers to
a place where souls go after death
if you describe a place as gloomy it is
dark and you cannot see very well as for
a person it means unhappy and without
hope
certainly not a very cheery place
one might say it was rather um gloomy
yes that's it do you know it no deal
oh there's a little sunspot little
snooty
hades refers to hercules as sunspot
because as you may have noticed the gods
and goddesses shine like the sun
check out this moment in the film where
hades uses sunspot to talk about
hercules
first you gotta turn the little sunspot
little snitchy refers to something small
and cute
and here is a sucker for the little
sucker
sucker is an informal name for a
lollipop if you say someone is a sucker
you mean they are a fool or an idiot
hey what makes you think you're coming
you're lucky
do i look like a sucker to you
[Music]
sheesh is an interjection used to
express frustration or annoyance
okay i'm gonna go look mom said this day
hidden i'm not gonna leave the cave
now let's watch three different scenes
where characters are using interjections
everything the light touches
is our kingdom
wow
you're reading these cool things i gotta
go work life is so unfair
[Music]
i guess i can show you a few moves
lauren's gonna teach you how to kick
butt
in which of them is the character
expressing frustration or annoyance
yeah powerful little take come on hades
don't be such a stiff
a tyke is a small child who behaves
badly
[Applause]
[Music]
to describe someone as stiff means they
are formal and controlled in a way that
is not friendly or relaxed check out
this example and pay attention to two
different words with similar meanings to
stiff
mom
could you remind me
why am i marrying this guy bala do we
have to argue about this again
we don't seem to have anything in common
the guys are stiff yes darling i know
the general may be a little gruff and
somewhat overbearing at times but
join the celebration
love to babe but unlike you gods
lounging about up here
the phrasal verb lounge about or around
means to spend time relaxing or doing
nothing
day or night
there was no one else
dawn to dusk my meals would come
i'd lounge about
in my home
i regrettably have a full-time gig that
you by the way so charitably bestowed on
me
zeus regrettably is used to say that you
are sad or sorry about something
ratatouille doesn't sound delicious it
sounds like rat
and patootie
rat patootie which does not sound
delicious
regrettably
we are all out of wine
the word gig informally means a job if
you have a full-time gig you work for
all the hours that are requested usually
40 hours a week
it's also used to describe a single
performance by a musician or group of
musicians especially playing modern or
pop music
i mean what
ah don't worry about it
being a regular dog is like the greatest
gig in the world okay
i regrettably have a full-time gig that
you by the way so charitably bestowed on
me
zeus
the word charitably comes from charity
if you do something charitably your
intention is to help someone in need if
you are kind and like to help people in
need you can be described as charitable
example people tend to be more
charitable at christmas time
to bestow something on or upon someone
means to give valuable property or an
important right or honour to someone
one more time hades is being sarcastic
here as he does not like his gig as the
god of the underworld
so it is with great great honor and a
humble heart that i bestow this pot of
honey upon our dear friend
balloon wonderful idea rabbit love to
but can't
you slow down
the modal verb ought to which means the
same as should is pronounced in two
different ways one is more common in
american english which was how zeus
pronounced it
ort ends with a t and two also starts
with a t when this happens we tend to
pronounce only one consonant sound in
order to facilitate the linking with the
next word
instead of saying ought to americans say
ara with a flap t
in british english however you are going
to hear a truthy or a glottal t
check out these examples first with an
american pronunciation and the second
with a british pronunciation
if jasmine found out i was really some
crummy street rat
she'd laugh at me a woman appreciates a
man who can make her laugh
ow
all joking aside
you really ought to be yourself hey
that's the last thing i want to be
kidding
through all this bit of rubbish all to
do
[Music]
we'll smoke the player out you took the
monster down no no
to learn more about how natives cut and
link words together make sure you check
out this lesson that ethan made over on
our other channel you can click up here
or the link down in the description box
below to watch that next
work yourself to death
[Music]
here zeus is joking around with the fact
that hades is the god of the underworld
if you work yourself to death you work
to the point of exhaustion
and you'll be happy to know that bees as
a species haven't had one day off in 27
million years
so you'll just work us to death we'll
sure try
[Music]
looks like your game's over wonder boy
is hitting every curve you throw at him
oh yeah
i wonder if maybe i haven't been
throwing the right
curves at him
meg my sweet
don't even go there see he's got to have
a weakness because everybody's got a
weakness i mean for what pandora was the
box thing for the trojans hey they bet
on the wrong horse okay
we
simply need to find out wonder boys i've
done my part get your little imps they
couldn't handle him as a baby i need
somebody who can
handle him as a man hey i've sworn off
manhandling well you know that's good
because that's what got you into this
jam in the first place isn't it you sold
your soul to me to save your boyfriend's
life
and how does this creep thank you
by running off of some babe
he hurt you real bad didn't he meg huh
look i learned my lesson okay which is
exactly why i got a feeling you're gonna
leap at my new offer
[Music]
mega rose one of hades servants hades
has been using her as a way to help him
execute his plan of defeating hercules
meg however is not on his side and it
seems hades plans have failed miserably
looks like your game's over wonder boy
is hitting every curve you throw at
oh
yeah
i wonder if maybe i haven't been
throwing the right
curves at him
meg my sweet
megara is referring to hercules as
wonder boy because he is successful and
has extraordinary abilities
you may be familiar with the
superheroine wonder woman
the idiom throw someone a curveball
comes from baseball and means to
surprise someone with something that is
difficult or unpleasant to deal with
example sometimes life throws a curve at
you when megura says hercules is hitting
every curve hades throws at him she
means hercules has been able to combat
hades attempts to destroy him
don't even go there see he's got to have
a weakness because everybody's got a
weakness if you are weak you are not
strong
weakness refers to the fact or state of
not being strong or powerful the
opposite of weakness is strength
pay attention to the examples
step fourth
the true path to victory is to find your
opponent's weakness and make him suffer
for it oh yeah
i mean because here's the thing
superhuman good looks i've always had
him born with it but superhuman strength
can you imagine the possibilities of
this
i mean for what pandora was the box
thing for the trojans hey they bet on
the wrong horse okay
we
simply need to find out wonder boys
pandora's box is an artifact in greek
mythology in which curiosity led her to
open a container she was told not to
consequently releasing physical and
emotional curses upon humanity
so if you open a pandora's books you do
or start something that will cause a lot
of problems
we call trojans the people from the
ancient city of troy however hades is
talking in reference to the trojan horse
that was the wooden horse used by the
greeks during the trojan war to enter
the city of troy and win the war as an
expression trojan horse refers to
something you accept because it seems
good but actually is intended to do bad
to bet on something means to risk money
on the result of an event or a
competition in the hope of winning more
money
example
luckily i bet 1 000 on the winning horse
also if you bet that something is true
or will happen you mean you are certain
of it
take a look at this example i can't wait
to see the queen and the princess i bet
they're absolutely
lovely i bet they are beautiful
i've done my part get your little imps
they couldn't handle him as a baby i
need somebody who can
handle him as a man
if you do your part you do something
that helps to achieve something
if we all stick together and we do our
part we can win this thing
i need somebody who can
handle him as a man
if you say that someone can handle a
problem a situation or even another
person you mean that they have the
ability to deal with it successfully
what do you got planned oh you sure you
can handle it come on you know who
you're talking to this is lightning
mcqueen i can handle anything
hey i've sworn off manhandling
when you swear off something you promise
to stop doing or using it example anne
decided to swear off social media
because it was consuming too much of her
time well you know that's good because
that's what got you into this jam in the
first place isn't it
here jam refers to a difficult situation
common collocations are to be in a jam
and get out of a jam
example i was in a jam after losing all
my money on a bet
you sold your soul to me to save your
boyfriend's life
and how does this creep thank you
we use the word creep to describe an
unpleasant person
no no no no murdering what you think i
swear for the jury i hope sid pulls your
voice box out yet
by running off of some babe
the phrasal verb to run off means to
leave a place unexpectedly we make a
great team the two of us we sure do
no doubt about it so what are you gonna
do just go running off to the wild by
yourself nope good
by running off of some
babe
the word babe is used informally to
describe an attractive person
couldn't have done it without you sugar
maybe
he hurt you real bad didn't he meg huh
did you notice that hades does not
pronounce didn't he as two separate
words in order to connect didn't with he
the t sound is dropped in didn't and the
h sound in he is reduced to e
so what we hear is
didn't it
check out this example he had you didn't
look i learned my lesson okay
if you learned a lesson you acquired a
great understanding of a situation by
going through difficult experiences
i only wanted to help and what did you
say to me fly home buddy i work alone it
tore me apart but i learned an important
lesson you can't count on anyone
especially your heroes which is exactly
why i got a feeling you're gonna leap at
my new offer
when you leap at something you
enthusiastically accept the chance to do
or have it example she leaped at the
offer for a better job
how sentimental
you know i haven't been this choked up
since i got a hunkamusaka caught in my
throat huh
so this is an audience or a mosaic
hey how you doing looking good nice
dress so hades you finally mean it are
things in the underworld well they're
just fine you know a little dark a
little gloomy and there's always hay
full of dead people what are you gonna
do which picture shows the opposite of
gloomy
[Music]
oh there's the little sunspot little
and here is a sucker for the little
sucker ah here you go
powerful little tike come on hades don't
be such a stiff join the celebration hey
love to babe but unlike you gods
lounging about up here i regrettably
have a full-time gig that you by the way
so charitably bestowed on me
zeus so
can't love to but can't
you slow down you work yourself to death
[Music]
work yourself to death
kill myself
if only
looks like your game's over wonder boy
is hitting every curve you throw at him
oh yeah
i wonder if maybe i haven't been
throwing the right
curves at him
meg my sweet
to throw a curveball at someone means
to hit them with a curvy object
to make them drive on curvy roads
to present them with a difficult and
unexpected problem
[Music]
don't even go there see he's got to have
a weakness because everybody's got a
weakness i mean for what pandora it was
the box thing for the trojans hey they
bet on the wrong horse okay
we
simply need to find out wonder boys i've
done my part get your little imps they
couldn't handle him as a baby i need
somebody who can
handle him as a man hey i've sworn off
manhandling
what should you swear off if you want to
make your english epic
procrastination
learning from your favorite shows
finding speaking partners on our app
well you know that's good because that's
what got you into this jam in the first
place isn't it you sold your soul to me
to save your boyfriend's life and how
does this creep thank you
by running off of some babe
he hurt you real bad didn't he meg huh
look i learned my lesson okay which is
exactly why i got a feeling you're gonna
leap at my new offer
[Music]
it's a human thing i'm kind of an expert
what does it mean
the thing you just said come on i'll
show you some more stuff